hello
my name is Alex Amancio creative
director on Assassin's Creed unity today
we're showcasing a heist mission the
hotel dia the oldest hospital in Paris
centuries older than the famous
notre-dame Cathedral which is down the
street the hospitals as we know them
haven't exactly been invented yet
so you're more likely to get sick inside
than to leave here the Templars are
using the building sewers to smuggle
their artifacts they stole from motrin
all go in and get the goods heists are a
specific type of co-op nishan different
from the Brotherhood missions that we've
already introduced here we have the
stealthily infiltrate a heavily guarded
location get to the treasure and steal
it without ever being seen let's use the
communal sense one of four co-op skills
and get a better picture of the
situation as you can see there are a lot
of guards patrolling in the graveyard so
we'll have to adapt our approach
according to their patrol locations and
paths fortunately enough this enemies
patrol panel takes him by a haystack
there are two guards behind this
mausoleum
let's coordinated and perform a Cinco
nicely done you can deactivate alarm
bells and prevent cars from calling
reinforcements should you get detected
let's jump
there is the chest heists have
randomized factors such as the location
of the chess number of guards in their
positions let's use strategy to clean
the room now that we have the treasure
we'll have to escape the area undetected
remember the more you get detected the
more the prize goes down
heists are highly replayable missions
you will be encouraged to play them to
get skill points special rewards and
also cash enabling you to better
customize our note this demo was another
glimpse of the Assassin's Creed unity
experience in unity you'll have the
freedom to carve your own unique path
but also to share your experience with
your friends thank you very much for
watching we'll see you again soon
mage history Assassin's Creed unity
pre-order now for two bonus offers the
guillotine spindle endgame get a chance
to win prizes every Friday and the
explosive chemical revolution mission
pre-order now